MEETING TO ORDER -- ZYRTEC
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE.
HERE MATHIS.
HERE AND HERE VERY HERE AND HERE
TO READ HERE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
I FLORA [inaudible]
QUIRK.
HERE WORK HERE -- WHEN?
IRWIN HERE JONES SAWYER HERE
JOHN SO YOU HEAR ME YOUR NAME
HERE ROBERT RIVAS.
FAMILY.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE REACHED A
QUORUM TO A START UP WITH MISTER
MATHIS AS HE'S HERE AB FIVE
NINETY AND I THINK FIRST OF ARE
YOU GOING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS MISTER MATHIS.
ALL RIGHT IN A MOTION WOULD BE
IN ORDER.
TO NO NO NO FIRST [inaudible]
FIRST. TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT.
RIGHT MR SO STOOD [inaudible]
MOVE [inaudible]
THE AMENDMENTS.
WITH THEIR SECOND FAVOURITE
SIGNATURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE AND THEN TO EIGHTY FIVE
NINETY EIGHT MEN HI EGGMAN TIME
MATHIS.
HI MATHIS I AM HERE CURRY.
AND YEAR THREE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
FLORA.
QUIRK LIVE WORK SITE IRWIN.
IRWIN NINE JONES SAWYER MARK
STONE SILLY AYE LEVINE AYE
LEVINE AYE ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
SALAS.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED
MISTER MATHIS YOU MAY PROCEED
UNLESS MISTER CORK AS A MINISTER.
REMEMBER IT'LL TAKE A LITTLE BIT.
A GREAT DEAL THAT -- JUST THE
LINES -- CALIFORNIA HEARING WILL --
THAT ARE VERY [inaudible]
MR KELLER.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT
ANYBODY ELSE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MICROPHONE.
I THINK I GOT YOUR ADDRESS ALL
RIGHT [inaudible]
THREATENING.
ANY.
ANYBODY SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL TODAY.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
MEMBERS.
OKAY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON A. B..
FIVE NINETY I NEED. TO PASS THIS
AMENDMENT TO APPROPRIATIONS
EGGMAN HI.
HI MATHIS FIVE NOT THIS TIME AB
A THREE YEAR PERIOD NINE
CUNNINGHAM.
FLORA. FOR FIVE WORK ON MY WHEN
I WENT ONLINE JONES SAWYER
SAILOR OFF.
JONES SAWYER ONLINE MOVIE HI
LEVINE AYE ROBERT RIVAS SAM.
HI THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU. ONE MORE THING ON THE
LINE.
THIS IS BILL.
THAT.
DOES STILL STANDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR MAKING A
COMPLICATED ISSUE LIKE MILK EASY
MR MATHIS.
THE FIRST TIME.
ALL RIGHT WORKING FOR MISTER
REAVIS OR MISTER MAYES.
THEIR SECOND.
THE BUT THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
TO APPROVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MISTER RIVERS JUST RIGHT THERE
SIR.
HI ON THE PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR EGGMAN HI.
HI MATHIS NIGHT HERE.
HERE I CAN ENHANCE.
FLORA. FOR MY FIRST NIGHT IRWIN
HI.
JOHN.
JONES SAWYER LEVINE.
LEVINE ROBERT RIVAS I NEVER READ
THE SIGNS YEAH.
THAT IS ADOPTED -- MISTER REAVIS
IS HEREBY TODAY PRESENTING ON AB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX AGRICULTURAL
LAND FOR SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THE REAL
ACT [inaudible]
OF EIGHT TWENTY NINETEEN
OPPORTUNITY A NEW OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SOCIALLY.
THE DISADVANTAGE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS TO GAIN ACCESS TO
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
AND SO UT A LOSSES OF
AGRICULTURE FOREMAN RANGE LAND
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION.
ANYA LOSSES AVERAGE AROUND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES PER YEAR.
AND SO SUCH LOSSES BECAUSE THIS
IS A A SERIOUS THREAT TO
AGRICULTURE.
CERTAINLY TO OUR LOCAL
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMIES -- AND TO
STATEWIDE FOOD PRODUCTION.
AND SO ACCORDING TO THE DATA
FROM THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CENSUS OF AGRICULTURE.
WE KNOW THAT THE AVERAGE AGE OF
OUR FARMERS IS RISING.
WITH THE CURRENT AVERAGE AGE OF
OF NEARLY SIXTY YEARS OLD.
WE ALSO SEE THE GAP BETWEEN MALE
AND FEMALE FARMERS CLOSING.
AS A NUMBER OF FEMALE FARMERS
HAS GROWN DRAMATICALLY SINCE THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
WE KNOW THAT AG PRODUCTION
EXPENSES HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY.
I AND GOVERNMENT SUPPORT IN THE
WAY FUNDING HAS ALSO INCREASED
OVER TIME.
WE ALSO SEE THE TRENDING SHIFT
TO LARGER AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS WITH CROP ACREAGE
BEING CONCENTRATED IN FEWER.
BUT LARGER FIRMS [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY -- WE SEE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ENTERING
AGRICULTURE DECLINING YEAR AFTER
YEAR AND THIS POTENTIAL SHORTAGE
OF CALIFORNIA FARMERS.
SHOULD BE ONE OF THE PRIMARY
PROBLEMS WE SEEK TO RESOLVE AS A
STATE.
I AS A FORM IS TOUGH.
NOW AND AND ENCOURAGING THE NEXT
GENERATION TO FARM TO BECOME
FARMERS IS AN INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGE.
AND SO INCREASINGLY HIGH LAND
PRICES LACK OF ACCESS TO
RESOURCES.
THESE ARE BARRIERS FOR ALL
FARMERS -- AND FOR SOCIALLY --
THE DISADVANTAGE FARMERS THESE
BARRIERS CAN BE EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED AND DIFFICULT TO
OVERCOME.
AND SO I COMMEND ASSEMBLYWOMAN
ARGUE ARE CURRY FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON AGRICULTURAL
ISSUES AND FOR HER WORK IN
CHAMPIONING THE FARMER QUITY
ACT OF OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW BY -- GOVERNOR
BROWN THE FORMER EQUITY ACT NOW
REQUIRES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE TO FOCUS ON
AND ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES
FACING FARMERS OF COLOR IN OUR
STATE.
BY MAKING ACCESS TO STATE AND
FEDERAL RESOURCES MORE EQUITABLE.
AND SO AS A RESULT OUR STATE --
MUST STRIVE TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
EQUITY.
WITHIN OUR AGRICULTURAL POLICIES
AND PROGRAMS.
I AM FOLLOWING THESE LINES THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH THE REAL
LOAN FUND PROGRAM A PROGRAM THAT
WOULD PROVIDE LOANS AND GRANTS
TO ARE SOCIALLY -- AT THE
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS AND CREATE OPPORTUNITY.
TO ACCESS FARMLAND AND RANGE
LAND OWNERSHIP OF OR LONG TERM
LEASES.
AND SO THIS BILLS EVERYTHING THE
FARMER EQUITY ACT INTENDED TO
ACCOMPLISH.
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT --
AB NINE EIGHT SIX WOULD LEAD TO
AN EQUITABLE INVESTMENT OF STATE
RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT THE FUTURE.
OF SOCIALLY.
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I DO HAVE A SOME
SPONSORS THAT ARE ALL OF THEM TO
DO SOME CELLS.
FIRST PERSON PLEASE YEAH GOOD
MORNING AUDIBLE CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MEMBERS OF I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
THE AUTHOR -- FOR THIS BILL -- I
BET SMOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARMER JUSTICE COLLABORATIVE AND
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND
OUR SPONSORS OF THE FARMER
EQUITY ACT WITH ASSEMBLY.
WOMAN I WE ARE CURRY -- THE
COLLABORATIVE REPRESENTS A
DIVERSE GROUP OF FARMERS OF
COLORS AND ALLIES WITH A SHARED
VISION OF A FAIR FOOD SYSTEM.
WHICH AIMS TO DISMANTLE
INJUSTICES IN THE FOOD SYSTEM AS
MY COLLEAGUES WILL EXPAND UPON
AND IS LIKELY NO SURPRISE TO ANY
OF YOU WE KNOW THAT ACCESS TO
LAND IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
OBSTACLES FARMERS FACE IN
SUCCESSFULLY FARMING.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF AG CENSUS THAT WAS RELEASED
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO CALIFORNIA
IS LOSING ON AVERAGE FOR FARMS
PER DAY.
AT THE SAME TIME THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF CALIFORNIA
FARMERS ARE SHIFTING WITH THE
NUMBERS OF SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS AND
RANCHERS INCREASING
EXPONENTIALLY ACROSS THE STATE.
IN ORDER FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REMAIN THE TOP PRODUCER OF OUR
NATION'S FOOD WITH SALES AT FOUR
FORTY FIVE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ACCORDING TO THE LAST
ACTS AND SAYS.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THE FARMERS
THAT OUR STATE IS BECOMING
DEPENDED ON TO GROW OUR FOOD.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT ACCESS TO
LANDS AND WITHOUT ALL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES PROVIDE DEEPER
CONTEXT ON THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PERSON
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT PLEASE
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
HORRIBLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- I DON'T THINK THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON AB -- NINETY SIX MY
NAME IS MICHAEL MILLION I'M HERE
TODAY WEARING TWO DIFFERENT HATS
I WORK FOR THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT AS THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY AGRICULTURAL PLAN.
I'M ALSO A VOLUNTEER POLICY
ADVISER -- FOR THE NONPROFIT
KITCHEN TABLE ADVISORS WHICH
SUPPORTS THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY
OF SMALL SMALL FARMS AND RANCHES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA -- MOSTLY
THROUGH ONE ON ONE BUSINESS
ADVISING PREDOMINATELY SERVING
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS.
SO AS A FORMER FARMER MYSELF AND
WITHOUT THE INHERITANCE OF LAND
FOR A FAMILY BUSINESS TO
CONTINUE -- I UNDERSTAND AND
SYMPATHIZE FIRST HAND HOW
DIFFICULT IT CAN BE ACCESS
FARMLAND.
IN MY CURRENT WORK -- I SIT ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE EQUATION THAT
THIS BILL WOULD IMPACT THAT THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA I MANAGED
AYE AN AGRICULTURAL CONSERVATION
EASEMENT PROGRAM.
THAT IS WORKING TO PROTECT
TWELVE THOUSAND ACRES OF
FARMLAND IS HIGHLY VULNERABLE --
TO DEVELOPMENT AND TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF SCALE OUR CONTACTS
THERE IN THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY HAS LOST --
45% OF ITS FARMLAND.
THAT SINCE -- NINETEEN NINETY
NINE SIDE KITCHEN TABLE ADVISERS
WHEN THE MOST COMMON AND MOST
DIFFICULT PROCESSES THAT WE WORK
WITH OUR CLIENTS ON IS FINDING
APPROPRIATE FARM LAND FOR
PURCHASE OR FOR LEASE SON BOTH
SIDES OF THIS EQUATION.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT WE DO NOT
YET HAVE ENOUGH TOOLS TO SUCCEED
IN BOTH PROTECTING FARMLAND IN
IN MAKING THAT LAND ACCESSIBLE
TO SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS.
AB NINE EIGHTY SIX PROVIDES A
REALLY NOVEL VEHICLE TO
ACCOMPLISH BOTH OF THOSE GOALS
AT ONCE.
SO QUICKLY -- A STORY ABOUT ONE
OF THE CLIENTS THAT WE WORK WITH
A KITCHEN TABLE ADVISORS -- HAVE
YEAR WAS ABLE TO GROW HIS
BUSINESS FROM LEASING ONE POINT
FIVE ACRES TO PURCHASING A TWO
HUNDRED ACRE RANCH A COUPLE
YEARS AGO.
FROM THE ONE POINT FIVE ACRES ON
LEASE TO THE TWO HUNDRED ACRES
HE NOW OWNS HAVE YOU EVER THE
BEEN BENEFICIARY OF MULTIPLE
WELL RESOURCE AND WELL ORGANIZED --
ENTITIES WORKING IN COORDINATION
WITH ONE ANOTHER TO PROTECT
FARMLAND AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT WAS ACCESSIBLE.
NOW THE REASON WHY I HAVE YEARS
SUCCESSFUL IS BECAUSE HE'S A
GOOD FARMER AND HE'S A GOOD
BUSINESSMAN HE JUST NEEDED THE
ACCESS TO LAND.
SO IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE A
STRATEGY WAS USED -- THAT'S
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS BY PROTECT
CELL WHERE ONE OR MORE
CONSERVATION ENTITIES POOL
RESOURCES TO BUY THE LAND FEE
TITLE PROTECTED WITH A
CONSERVATION EASEMENT AND THEN
SELL IT BACK TO A NEW FARMER.
NOW IN OUR COUNTY AND IN MUCH OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU'RE REDUCING
THE VALUE OF LAND BY PUTTING A
CONSERVATION EASEMENT IT'S AT A
RATE OF FIFTY TWO IN OUR COUNTY
75% OF THE VALUE.
SO THIS IS AN OFTEN OVERLOOKED
SIDE I THINK OF AGRICULTURAL
CONSERVATION EASEMENTS THAT THE
NOT ONLY PROTECTING THE LAND IN
PERPETUITY THEY'RE ALSO
PERMANENTLY REDUCING THE COST OF
THAT LAND AND THEREFORE IT'S
ACCESSIBILITY.
SO IN MY WORK AT THE COUNTY I
REGULARLY FIELD CALLS FROM --
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
INTERESTED IN LEASING OR BUYING
PROTECTED LAND AND FROM RETIRING
FARMERS WHOSE KIDS DON'T WANT TO
FARM AND WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
MADE FINANCIALLY HOLE ON THEIR
PROPERTY INVESTMENT BUT WITHOUT
SEEING THEIR LAND DEVELOPED.
SO GIVEN THE EXTRAORDINARILY
HIGH SPECULATIVE VALUATION OF
FARMLAND IN OUR COUNTY AND
ACROSS CALIFORNIA - MY PROGRAM
CANNOT CONNECT THE DOTS BETWEEN
THESE TWO GROUPS -- NOT WITHOUT
THIS HERCULEAN EFFORT OF COURT
NATION AND A MOUNTAIN OF
RESOURCES TO DO THAT BY PROTECTS
TO SELL A STRATEGY.
AB -- NINETY SIX WOULD ALLOW ME
TO DO THAT IN OUR PROGRAM --
WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS -- AND HANDED OVER.
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME'S OF AND
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB --
NINETY SIX ID COME FROM SANTA
ANA I AM A MEMBER OF A WORKER
COOPERATIVE -- THAT WE ARE WE'RE
FOR MEMBERS AND WE FARM AND
WE'VE BEEN FARMING OUT OF FOR
THREE YEARS IN THE BACK OF A LOT
IN IT WHICH WE BORROW FROM A
CHURCH.
AND SAW -- DONE THE WAY THAT OUR
MISSION WITH THE CHURCH IS
BASICALLY A MONTH TWO MONTHS
WITH -- BASICALLY IF IT'S NOT
FOR THE GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH
THAT WE HAVE WITH THE WITH THE
CHURCH LIKE THEY MIGHT NOT BE
THAT WE'RE WE'RE NOT FARMING
NEXT MONTH ANYMORE YOU KNOW.
AND SO THAT'S A THAT'S THE
UNFORTUNATE IN OUR SITUATION --
THE FOCUS OF MY OF MY A
TESTIMONY TODAY -- WILL BE ON
THE SPIRITS OF SANTANA ASYLUM --
AGRICULTURAL -- ASPIRING FARMERS --
HOW ARE WE TRYING TO ACQUIRE
LAND AND THE OBSTACLES -- TO GET
IT.
AND SO ON I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH SANTANA BUT IT'S
SITUATED IN ORANGE COUNTY IT'S
IN THE MIDDLE ORANGE COUNTY.
AND SO -- IT'S A COMMUNITY THAT
FOR GENERATIONS HAS BEEN -- US
ON CULTURAL STRONGHOLD OF
MEXICAN CULTURE.
AND SO -- FOR MEAN IT MANY OF US
WHO MIGRATED -- TWO SANTANA IT'S
IT'S A PLACE THAT WE CALL HOME
IT'S LIKE OUR HOME AWAY FROM
HOME AND SO IT'S THE THE THE
FOOD.
THE MUSIC EVERYTHING HAS BEEN.
THE MANNERISMS OF THE PEOPLE
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD.
OUR COMMUNITY TO BE IN IN A
COMMUNITY THAT WE LOVE --
SOMETHING IS ALSO A PLEASE
THAT'S VERY HARD TO LIVE --
BASICALLY IT'S NOT IT'S NOT RARE
FOR OUR FAMILIES TO LIVE -- MANY
FAMILIES IN ONE APARTMENT OR IN
A HOUSE -- THIS IS BECAUSE THE
THE PRICE OF THE PROPERTY IS
REALLY HIGH [inaudible]
AND SO -- MANY OF THE THE ARE
ARE CONTEXT OF LIVING A FORCES
US TO COME TOGETHER NOW AND SO
MANY PEOPLE HAVE COME TOGETHER
AROUND HOUSING ISSUES.
IMMIGRATION ISSUES AND IN OUR
CASE -- BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTHY FOOD WE CREATED THOUGHT
COOPERATIVE TO A GIRL FOOD --
FOR OUR OUR NEIGHBORS AND
OURSELVES.
SOLO BUT THIS -- BUT THIS WAY A
OF THE THE OBSTACLES THAT I I OF
THE IT HAS BEEN MENTIONED IT
APPLIES TO US.
AND IN MANY CASES IT'S EVEN
WORSE BECAUSE MANY OF US DON'T
HAVE -- PROPERTY OR ANY ASSETS
THAT -- THAT WE CAN COME UP
FOURTH AND SAW.
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS -- A LAND
SHOWS THAT WAS CREATED WAS A MAN
TOOL. TO CREATE A STRATEGY FOR
OUR FARMERS AND COMMUNITY PEOPLE
TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE.
TO HAVE ACCESS TOOL -- LAND TO
OWN IT.
AND SO -- THIS HAS AT THIS IT
WAS CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND SINCE THEN --
ALTHOUGH WE'VE BEEN ABLE -- TO
COMING TOOL ON NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE CITY FOR ONE BACON Là --
SOME OF THE OBSTACLE HAS BEEN
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY **** TOOL
SHOW FOR AND SO WE CAN GET A
LOAN.
AND SO THAT HAS KINDA LIKE
EXTENDED OUR NEGOTIATIONS TOOL
TO THIS POINT.
IT'S NOT FOR SURE WHETHER WE'RE
GONNA GET IT BUT THE POINT IS
THAT -- WITHOUT THOSE ASSETS --
IT MAKES IT THAT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE -- TO BE
ABLE TO GET A CAR THAT LINE.
AND SO.
I THINK. ONE OF THE MAIN POINT
IS THAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT --
TO REMARK IS THAT -- IT'S THE
IT'S THE IT'S THAT FIRST -- FOOT
A FOOT IN THE DOOR.
SO WE NEED WE NEED THAT SUPPORT --
TO GET THEIR FOOT IN THE DOOR
BECAUSE ONCE WE HAVE LAND WILL
BE ABLE TO USE THAT.
AND KEEP GROWING THE LET A TO BE
ABLE TO A SECURE LAND IN
SOMETHING ELSE SO THAT WE CAN
NOT PRESERVE IT.
OUT OF THE SPECULATIVE MARKET
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
BEGIN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
TODAY.
PLEASE JUST NAME AND AFFILIATION
[inaudible]
NOTHING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER FOR THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY OPEN SPACE THIRTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL TOWERS WITH THE COMMUNITY
LINES WITH FAMILY FARMERS AND
THE CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KATIE PATTERSON
WITH AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH MARKETS REPRESENTING
CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ERNESTO MAYES A WHAT THE
NATIONAL FARMERS COALITION
FIRMLY CAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
AARON RODRIGUEZ WITHIN IN A
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I NOTICED SO WELL WITH THE
RIGHTS AND SANTA ANA CLT.
THANK YOU.
ON OCCASION.
OF MEDIA ALLIANCE FOR
AGROECOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA FROM
JUSTICE COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN CAMERA READY WITH SUSTAINABLE
CONNERY'S LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THE BODIES BEGIN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS TO THE
RUSSIAN WITH A CALIFORNIA FROM
YOUR WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION -- BUT AT AT
THE PLEASURE OF THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE TO SORT OF OFFER SOME OF
OUR CONCERNS THAT WE DO HAVE
WITH THE BILL.
AND SO I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST I I WANT TO SAY WE
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL THAT
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS HAVE.
REAL ISSUES TO ACCESSING CAPITAL
TO PURCHASE OR TO LEASE LAND.
AND TO LACKS SOME OF THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OF THE
TECHNICAL KNOW HOW ON HOW TO
UNDERSTAND AG FINANCING I THINK.
DOES HAVE COMPLETE VALUE IN
HAVING DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW WE
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THAT ISSUE --
BUT I THINK PRACTICALLY WE DO
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS WITH -- HOW
THE BILL IS CRAFTED THAT WE LOVE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS ON I THINK?
FIRST AND FOREMOST BEYOND THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A SEPARATE GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE.
FOR AMONG OTHER CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO ACQUIRE ACLAND HOLD
ITS PLACE UNDER AN AGRICULTURAL
EASEMENT AND THEN EITHER
IDENTIFY.
A SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGE FARMER
RANCHER TO LEASE THAT LANDS OR
TWO THEN ACQUIRE THAT LAND AS
WELL OR TO TRANSFER THE FEE
TITLE [inaudible]
I'M.
I THINK IT.
WE HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT.
THE BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THIS
GRANT RECIPIENTS OF A COUNTY OR
A CITY IN IN ONE CIRCUMSTANCE.
TO ACQUIRE WHAT ONCE WAS
PRODUCTIVE ACLAND AND WITH NO
MANDATE TO MANAGE THAT LAND
INTERMITTENTLY WHILE THEY FIND
THAT SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS RANCHER WE HAVE SOME
REAL CONCERNS THAT THAT MIGHT
LEAD TO ATLANTA BEING TAKEN OUT
OF PRODUCTIVITY.
THERE'S ALSO NO TIMELINE ON WHEN
THAT TRANSFER INSTANCE TO HAPPEN
SO IT COULD BE A MUCH LONGER
SITUATION I THINK WE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
FEE TITLE ACQUISITION.
ATTY EASEMENT CONTRACTS ARE
COMPLICATED I THINK WE THE
SPONSORS ECHOED THAT SENTIMENT --
AND SO WITHOUT THOSE PARAMETERS
IT MAKES IT REALLY DIFFICULT TO
SEE THAT THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE THE ANTITHETICAL A FACT
THAT IT'S INTENDED TO DO.
I BEYOND THAT THE BILL ALSO
DOESN'T HAVE.
ANY CONSIDERATION THAT THAT THE
LAND THAT'S REQUIRED BY THAT
GRANT RECIPIENTS IS PRODUCTIVE
ATLANTA SO IT COULD BE NON PRIME
LAND WHICH IS.
NOT THE GREATEST OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS OR RANCHERS TO FIND --
ECONOMIC PRODUCTIVITY THERE'S NO
STANDARD THAT THERE BE WATER
AVAILABILITY ON THAT LANDS WHICH
EVERY FARMER I THINK DEALS WITH
NOW IN THIS CLIMATE -- OR THAT
IT'S THE APPROPRIATE SIZE THAT
CAN ACCOMMODATE A TRULY
PRODUCTIVE -- ACT PLOT -- I I'M
WORRIED THAT WITHOUT THESE
PARAMETERS PUT IN A SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGE DISADVANTAGE FARM
AND RANCH RIGHT RANCHER WHO IS.
DISENFRANCHISED TO BEGIN WITH
IT'S GOING TO BE SOLD AN
OPPORTUNITY IS THIS IS YOUR WAY
TO BREAK INTO FARMING AND
RANCHING OR TO ELEVATE YOURSELF --
WITH LAND THAT'S NOT REALLY
GOING TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE THAT
AND I THINK THAT'S PART OF OUR
CONSIDERATION.
AND THEN FINALLY I THINK WE HAVE
AND WE'RE CERTAINLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE AYE
CONSERVATION EASEMENT PIECE OF
THAT SWEET WHOLEHEARTEDLY AS AS
FARM BUREAU AGREE THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PROTECTED -- BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN FUNDS OR WE
CAN MODIFY THERE'S LOTS OF
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST BUT THAT
LOCALLY.
PRIVATELY AT THE STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL -- WHIMS ENACT
SALTS CFC PIECE FARM LOAN
PROGRAMS THAT ALL CAN SERVE THIS
PURPOSE AND WE CAN PRIORITIZE
THESE FOLKS IN THOSE PROGRAMS.
SO WE ASK THAT WE FUND THOSE
PROGRAMS ARE WE LOOK AT THOSE
PROGRAMS FIRST BEFORE CREATING
SOMETHING NEW SO ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE VERY HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH BOTH OF THEM AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR OUR LATE --
CONSIDERATIONS BUT WE DID FEEL
AS THOUGH THOSE DISCUSSIONS WERE
WORTHY OF HAVING IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND IN THE NEXT OKAY --
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE BEGIN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE QUESTION COMES FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU I'M FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL I JUST WANT TO IT.
THERE'S AN ARTICLE TODAY IN THE
PAPER REGARDING -- HOW ARE
FARMING FAMILIES ARE FALLING
APART AND NOT WANTING TO GO BACK
TO THE FAMILY FARM?
AND OUR FARMERS ARE GETTING
OLDER.
ANY OPPORTUNITY THAT WE CAN GIVE
FARMERS TO HAVE DIFFERENT
ALTERNATIVES TO HAVE
DISADVANTAGED FAIL -- FARMERS
COME IN AND MAYBE LEASE THE LAND
OR BY THE LAND -- I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE GIVE THEM
THAT OPPORTUNITY -- I APPRECIATE
HOW HARD YOU WORK TO TRY TO GET
THIS ALL TO WORK.
I KNOW YOU CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS -- AND I APPRECIATE IT
AND I WOULD HOPE THAT THE FARM
BUREAU HELPS OUT.
AND COMES TO THE TABLE MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT TO HELP OUT OUR
FARMERS OF THE FUTURE BECAUSE WE
DO NEED MORE FARMERS.
AND SOMETIMES THERE IS A
DISCONNECT -- WITH SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT JUST
POINTING OUT FARM YOUR WITH
OTHERS THAT SHOULD BE HELPING
OUT ALL ALONG.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
BILL AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY.
TAKE IT AS A MOTION.
THAT WOULD BE YEP.
THANK YOU IT'S BEEN A MOTION AND
A SECOND ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
MR MATHIS MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU --
MISTER USA APPRECIATE THE TIME
SPEAKING WITH YOU I THINK YOUR
BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BE A
GREAT BILL -- UNFORTUNATELY I
DON'T THINK ALL THE PIECES ARE
THERE YET -- I WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU TO GET IT TO WHERE
I BELIEVE IT TO THE NEEDS TO BE
THERE THAT WAY ARE PEOPLE WHO.
ARE TRYING TO STEP OUT OF
POVERTY AND GET INTO
AGRICULTURAL ACTUALLY HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO HAVE GOOD LANDS TO
BE ABLE TO INVEST IN.
IN TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYTHING
IS PUT TOGETHER RIGHT SO WE'RE
NOT SELLING THEM HOPES AND
DREAMS -- THAT ARE GOING TO BE.
YOU KNOW WHERE THE TO BE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO GROW ANYTHING --
SO FOR THAT REASON I'M GONNA LAY
OFF -- VERSES OPPOSING YOUR BILL
TODAY -- BUT I WOULD LIKE A
SOLID COMMITMENT FROM YOU -- TO
WORK WITH THIS TO ENSURE THAT --
ALL THE RIGHT PIECES GET PUT
INTO THIS SO IT'LL ACTUALLY BE
EQUITABLE ON TO ENSURE THIS
PROGRAM WILL WORK RIGHT --
MOVING FORWARDS THESE PEOPLE CAN
TRULY BE TAKEN CARE OF AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
YOU KNOW WE DID HAVE A BRIEF.
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT THIS
MORNING TO LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU YOU KNOW I MASS YOU
KNOW ABSOLUTELY.
MAIL.
COMMITTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS THIS A STRONG BEYOND A STRONG
PROGRAM AND AND THE WAY THAT --
WE CAN GET THERE IS BY HAVING --
CLUB APPROACH TO MAKING SURE
THAT ALL THESE ISSUES ARE
ADDRESSED AT THE UP SOME VERY
VALID CONCERNS AND Là FOR
WORKING WITH YOU ON THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
NOTHING ELSE.
OKAY BUT CAN I TRUST YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH WITH WITH
ALL SIZE AND FIND A WORKABLE
SITUATION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MISTER.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
BOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECURE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY SIX THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS EGGMAN BY EGGMAN
AYE MATHIS.
MATH IS NOT LOADING AGUIAR-CURRY.
A GEAR CURRY I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM NOT LOADING FLORA.
LARA NOT VOTING QUIRK.
QUIRK GUY -- WHEN -- WHEN NIGHT
JONES SAWYER?
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT
RIVAS SIZE SALAS [inaudible]
SALAS SIGN.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER REAVIS.
CAN ADD MEMBERS TO SOME OF THE
PREVIOUSLY FOR BILLS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible] ELEVEN
FLORA.
AND SO OFTEN.
CUNNINGHAM AYE FLORA AYE
[inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I AND SALAS.
SALAS SIDE.
AND ON A. B. [inaudible]
FIVE NINETY CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
FLORA.
FLORA I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIZE SALAS
[inaudible]
SALAS SIDE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM MY OKAY THAT'S A WRAP
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEETING
ADJOURNED [inaudible]
MMHM
.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE FROM THE
AFTERNOON THING [inaudible]
OR NOT [inaudible]
YEAH THE